who how much money do you think
zuckerberg and uh twitter
face how much money do you think they
give to the democrats
hundreds of millions in in in funding
of tax and other things they own the
democratic party
that's why they're doing they don't do
any censorship in favor of trump
the censorship is against trump and to
elect a guy they control joe biden
if biden is elected we will be subjected
to this censorship
for the next four years because they're
in league together
the reason they despise trump is because
trump basically tells him to go to hell
he's not he's not going to let them run
this country
he wasn't elected he has lost
contributors because of this
he's had contributors come to him and
say why don't you just go easier on the
big tech companies
and he's basically throwing him out of
his office i mean the reality is
that big tech and the big media
this is the first president they can't
push around
because basically big tech and big media
is is what he says to the enemy of the
people
when you deprive the american people of
critical information about a
presidential election
you're really not a journalist it's some
kind of political hack
let's read the email of january
3 2019 in which hunter biden
tells his tells his daughter
that for 30 years he's been collecting
money for the family
he has to pay the expenses of the family
and then he has to give half of it to
his father so this is about joe biden
using his son in a most horrible way
as a bad man or or it could have been
that
hunter was exaggerating things and
saying things that
his father didn't know look i just want
to get to the censorship of the story
then then why do the texts
have him explaining to his father what
he's doing because we don't have any
we passed out a long time ago we have
text messages
where joe biden is dealing with burisman
we have a witness now mr bubalinski
who's in who's a uh retired navy officer
discharged honorably not thrown out for
drugs like hunter
who says that there were frequent
discussions between joe and his father
about the money they were making in
china from the chinese communists
so we can we can disregard that too okay
just tell me about the fact that the
problem is
there's not a there's never enough
evidence there's such a stark difference
between the
directions in which the two candidates
would take the country
i mean donald trump would take it in the
direction of
free enterprise continued growth in our
economy which
he brought to the highest point it's
ever been right before the pandemic
beyond any other american president more
jobs higher income
better growth then all of a sudden we
got hit by the pandemic and all the
democrats were predicting
two-year depression 25 unemployment
we'll never get out of it it'll take
years and here we are once
three four months later we had three
months of record job growth
record each month set a record for job
growth our uh gdp growth
this year was this is uh this this month
was uh
phenomenal 33 and a third percent that's
three times higher than our record in
the past
and the end result of all this is we're
about
75 to 80 percent of the way back we're
further back than any
uh any of our allies by far we've got a
stronger economy than
any any of them well that's our economy
faster even though in many ways
we will want to hit pretty much one of
the hardest well let's say
about one thing about donald trump is
you can't quarrel with the fact that
he's masterful and guiding the economy
and
in that area there's not many people
that dispute that and biden of course
has never guided an economy and has some
really infantile ideas like raising
taxes is going to help growth britain
certainly wants a post-brexit deal
with china you're uh close to this
country you have an honorary
knighthood what happens if uh if trump
is re-elected or if biden is elected as
regards a special relationship
uh given that britain is leaving on new
year's eve well i
i have a tremendous regard for for great
britain and i think the president does i
think it was
it was clearly evidence when he visited
there how close he feels
to england and to the british government
uh
the pr the president's problem with our
allies in europe
is they don't pay their bills major
problem is germany
germany is a very rich country they only
pay
about less than half of what they're
supposed to pay for nato